hip hop Games le 17 novembre Sandrine
Hector Frédéric Lignol vous restez en
plateau avec nous on passe du rap du
hiphop cultures urbaines au rock cette
fois-ci avec loup de montis nouvel album
qui sort hziy avenue voilà qui est ici
qui s'affichera également sur votre
écran on va en parler vous allez nous
jouer aussi un petit extrait juste un
mot tout d'abord vous êtes un hky Tonk
man c'est-à-dire que vous êtes partout
vous jouez partout vous partez sur les
routes avec votre guitare et il faut
partager la musique avec tout le monde
la musique pour tous par tous c'est ça
votre créau c'est ça mon créneau comme
le Hipop aussi on est là à partir du
momentù on fait quelque chose
d'artistique on le fait pas pour garder
pour soi on essaie de l'apporter au plus
de gens possible évidemment he c'est ça
le but et et d'espérer en tout cas que
ce qu'on essaie de faire ben ils vont
l'apprécier voilà je parlais du rock
c'est pas forcément le label que vous
préférez il en faut un donc c'est le
rock mais pour autant le rock ça vient
du blues c'est on on a tendance
maintenant dans les années 2000 les
années 2000 à mettre un peu sous
certains labels beaucoup de choses donc
le rock ça veut tout dire évidemment ça
veut rien dire je pense qui est
important c'est voilà c'est de pouvoir
s'exprimer d'une façon qui vous
correspond he qui vous fait plaisir
évidemment vous allez pas faire quelque
chose que vous n'aimez pas moi on me met
sous la belle du rock bon c'est le
labelle du rock je vais avec ça ça me va
très bien voilà 30 ans de carrière plus
de 30 ans de carrière vous avez débuté à
13 ans oui c'est vrai à 13 ans vous avez
commencé par quoi parter dans votre
garage tout mond un amateur de rock qui
se respecte voilà c'est ça ben on avait
pas les moyens d'aujourd'hui mais bon
voilà on a commencé par apprendre à
jouer de la guitare déjà et j'ai trou
très vite utilisé la guitare comme un
moyen de comment pouvoir m'exprimer pour
écrire des chansons ça toujours été mon
mon mon but je dirais voà ma passion
donc voilà donc j'ai depuis l'âge de 13
ans j'écris des chansons évidemment on
en écrit des bonnes les moins bonnes
mais puis voilà on continue à évoluer 30
ans plus tard on est toujours là voilà
avec la guitare aussi qui est toujours
là c'est peut-être pas la même remarqué
mais elle vous accompagne ce soir je
vais vous laisser la prendre pour
pouvoir n nous interpréter un morceau un
extrait de ce nouvel album un extrait
tout à fait on pourrait peut-être
pourrait peut-être chanter toute la nuit
mais bon voilà on va faire un petit
exrait quand même d'un morceau qui
s'appelle heart of FO donc c'est le
dernier album on y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avenu
there is some night where I feel all
alone my heart is like a piece of
Stoney and fragile but I you all al it's
hard to always be so
strong you took away
my
te it
upon you took a
my
you to
BL i'm the full
any
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lou de mon sur Plô pour un live
acoustique merci pour l'extrait de cet
album on avenue qui est votre nouvel
album vous chantez en anglais on a pu
l'entendre et c'est pas un hasard vous
avez passé 20 ans en Angleterre plus de
20 ans ou plus de 20 ans en Angleterre
pourquoi avoir quitté la France pourquoi
être revenenu aussi d'ailleurs parce que
le RO c'est là-bas c'est en Angleterre
non pas forcément non non j'étais un
artiste signé sur une majore en France
et le climat voilà ne me convenait pas
et à force de lire dans les journaux que
c'est toujours mieux ailleurs le Hipop
c'est pareil on va aller aux États-Unis
on va voir tout ça on veut le vivre il y
en a qui le font ro ça se vit en
Angleterre aussi à l'Angleterre voilà
donc je suis parti là-bas et j'y suis
resté bon je suis revenu je suis content
d'être revenu mais ça m'a permis
effectivement de d'apprendre à
travailler d'une autre manière le rock
c'est en Angleterre il y a des artistes
aussi qui vont se produire en Angleterre
bientôt sont les Stones vous Z peut-être
aller les voir j'aimerais bien ou vous
avez pas prévu de réserver un billet
ouais ils m'ont pas je suis Déu les
places son très ch son chers à trouver
et puis cher effectivement pour le
portefeuille petit détail on parlait de
l'Angleterre mais cet album qui vient de
sortir est 100 % éelinois il est 100 %
éelinois ouais tout à fait donc là
l'équipe qui joue donc musiciens sont
tous du mentoi la production a été faite
dans le mentoi voilà c'est un produit
vraiment de menthe la vidéo donc vous
voyez les exement qui VO qu'on ver unu
tout à l'heure a été tourné dans les
usines Sulzer alors usines Sulzer c'est
ça remonte loin parce que c'est une
usine qui s'est installée en 1956 ça
manque la ville évidemment comme toute
usine ça a créé voilà on a étéé de
construire des maisons pour faire venir
ses ouvriers voilà qu'il puissent
habiter là et tout enfin c'est vraiment
une grosse partie de l'histoire du
menttoi on a fait ce tournage là
maintenant malheureusement ça devenir un
hyper marché
il y a un engagement donc derrière
également pour cet artiste on l'entend
il pourrait venir sur Saint-Quentin il
vient de l'immer je vais vendre un petit
peu merci pour asser un projet sur sa
peut-être il y a des espaces il y a le
scarabé la enfin il y a des scènes qui
proposent qui travaillent sur le sur la
musique rock pose cette question parce
qu'il donne des cours également vous
êtes enseignant je je suis artiste je
suis c'est artiste intervenant à l'école
des Kadar effectivement donc je fais
aussi des projets pédagogiques et
j'essaie de passer d'une manière tout à
fait modeste voilà ce que j'ai appris à
l'étranger et voilà de mettre ça en
forme voilà ici dans le Manoi c'est très
intéressant peut-être prochainement à
saintquenttin on yine voilà de l'autre
côté du département est-ce qu'il y a des
dates qui sont prévues pour accompagner
la sortie de cet album ma prochaine date
là ça sera le 25 novembre à Paris dans
une péniche voilà c'est un lieu assez en
new com dit en anglais c'est pas commun
donc voilà dans une péniche La Péniche
Mar Counet qui est basée au pontmie dans
le 4e derrière Notre-Dame ça sera le
dimanche 25 novembre et ça sera à 6h une
émission de radio et après il y a un
concert privé mais tout le monde est
bienvenu de voilà et pour vous suivre
également le site internet he forcément
on y trouvera toutes les information je
rappelle également les hip hop Games
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure ce
sera le 17 novembre et donc cet album de
Lou de montis on va regarder très
rapidement un petit extrait de de ce
clip command qui accompagne c'est le
premier clip qui accompagne cet album
qui est disponible sur les plateformes
téléchargement légal euh c'est inter
voilà c'est j'ai une licence avec un
label qui s'appelle car de lune et c'est
distribué par sucadis dans toute la
France VO tous les magasins et puis
c'est aussi en téléchargement dans tous
les sites voilà si dès à présent vous
pouvez télécharger légalement c'est
parti et on regarde un petit extrait ce
clip avant de conclure ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon on sera bien rester plus longtemps à
vous écouter on est toujours pris par le
temps forcément mais merci d'être venu
donc sur le plateau merci à tous les
invités qui sont venus vu ce soir on va
juste revenir sur l'une de ces
informations du jour information
importantes les médecins étaient en
grève ils manifestaient devant le
ministère de la Santé à contre la
politique du gouvernement qui menace
selon eux la médecine libérale des
médecins de trappe de la clinique était
présent nous les avons rencontré Valérie
oribau Guillaume coms chirurgien de la
main à l'hôpital de trappe Christian
couturier refuse d'être pris pour un
pigeon en grève illimitée depuis lundi
il a rejoint ce mercredi ses confrères
et consœurs pour manifester devant le
ministère de la Santé à Paris la à cause
de cette grogne l'accord sur les
dépassements d'honorair signé fin
octobre par trois syndicats de médecins
les médecins libéraux dénoncent
l'attitude de la ministre de la Santé
Marie sol Touren à leur égard la plupart
des médecins ont été humiliés par le le
comportement et surtout le le ce que le
la ministre de la Santé a dit parce
qu'effectivement on a l'impression
d'avoir été montré du doigt alors que
nous sommes plutôt des gens vertueux
nous travaillons pour soigner les
patients pour leur apporter
du bien-être et si nos tarifs opposables
les tarifs qui les remboursent n'ont pas
augmenté depuis 30 ans ben c'est pas de
notre faute en secteur 2 le docteur
couturier a créé à l'hôpital de trappe
l'un des plus importants centres SOS
Main de France il exerce pour plus de 55
% de son activité au tarif opposable
fixé par la loi et rappelle qu'une
petite centaine de médecins seulement
appliquent un dépassement d'honoraire
audelà du raisonnable selon lui l'ordre
des médecins est là pour réguler ces
dérapages mais il pointe surtout du
doigt le comportement des mutuels de
santé l'argent de la santé existe et
l'argent de la santé les Français l'ont
déjà déboursé il faut simplement le
trouver au bon endroit et il est
certainement pas chez les médecins qui
n'ont rien augmenté depuis des années il
est là où je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
sur les assurances complémentaires qui
ne redistribu pas les 7 milliards
d'euros de bénéfices qu'elles font tous
les ans le docteur couturier a rejoint
cet après-midi les 2000 manifestants
selon les organisateurs pour scander sa
colère à ses côtés ses confrères
trapistes qui attendent beaucoup de la
manifestation
que les rediscussions soi prises avec
nos représentants c'estàdire syndicat le
bloc qui représente donc les chirurgiens
les gynécologues et les anesthésistes
pour que soit rediscuté donc les les
conditions et les décisions prises sur
notamment les compléments
d'honoraire on est une clinique privée
et on est ce qu'on appelle PDS c'estàd
qu'on a on a une mission de service
public nuit profonde donc on a été
réquisitionné moi je ne suis pas
réquisitionné aujourd'hui mais je pense
mon petit doigt me dit que je le serai
demain puisque mes collègues l'ont été
mes deux collègues l'ont été avanthier
et hier maintenant je suis tout à fait
disposé je suis tout à fait prêt à
continuer à ne travailler que sur
réquisition un jour par semaine voilà il
y a pas de problème depuis le début de
la semaine 90 % du personnel du secteur
chirurgie de l'hôpital de traap est en
grève les médecins en grève mobilisés à
Paris c'était donc aujourd'hui prochaine
édition du 78 demain 15h d 18h pour le
direct nous reviendrons sur l'actualité
locale forcément avec une large séquence
consacrée à l'économie solidaire le
maire socialiste de trappe guimalandin
sera sur ce plateau à quelques jours
d'une conférence sur ce thème dans sa
ville en présence du Ministre Benoît
amont je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée à
demain